all right everybody it is the Drew
magazine happy Place Celebration and now
joining Rossi
East the New York Times best-selling
author actor and featured in this issue
of Drew magazine please welcome someone
I like to call my friend Jenny Mullins
[Applause]
well I'm certainly a friend of the show
how many times have you been on now it's
like five or six at least I think so I
know I think it's like six it could be
six Jenny would you uh hit the headlines
with us the way you contributed
all right take it away okay so People
magazine reports that Penn badgeley's
toddler recently saw him on screen as
you the serial killer Joe
and recognized him as Daddy that's right
so Penn says he scrambled to turn off
the TV before the two and a half year
old saw something very crazy yeah
because well crazy stuff goes down on
that show you know what I mean and you
don't want your kids seeing that but it
made me think of you like have your kids
seen Jason and what he did to that pie I
mean how do you explain that away no not
yet my oldest is nine years old so I
mean you'd have to call Child Protective
Services if they had seen that already
yeah but no we were we were actually in
Austria this winter and a guy did come
up to us and he's like you you're the
guy you're the guy who Stoops the apple
cake and I'm like oh my God I my son
sort of looked over but he didn't quite
put it together thank God thank God all
right next up a woman writes to The
Washington Post Miss Manners call and we
love Miss Manners and says her husband
takes candid photos of her and sometimes
sends them without her permission to
family friends and even co-workers can
you imagine she told him she does not
like it but he just laughs it off and
says she looks cute well Miss Manners
tells this woman she needs to dig into
why her husband isn't listening to her
when she says not to I just say
um throw away his phone
I think husbands have a gauge of what's
cute and what's not like don't tell me
you know it's cute like they can't
decide if I don't think it's cute it's
not cute I think that he might Jason has
like two settings on his phone one is
like
somewhat hideous and one is like land
monster hideous
and we could literally take the same
shot together at the exact same time and
why do I look infinitely better in my
picture than I do in it is it because
you know your angle because you know
it's happening what is it I don't know
he's just like I don't know what he's
doing I can't imagine you taking a bad
picture though guys go to his Instagram
it's like two different people it's like
on my Instagram everything looks great
and then when you see Jason like who
he's married to in real life on his page
it's a it's a disaster it's a whole
other story
right exactly
Jenny you mentioned Austria it's your
happy place and that's what's in our
magazine and you were just there again
recently yes I love it I mean why do you
love Austin I love Austria well I speak
German yes I lived in Germany uh and I
I've you know forced that on my children
so they speak German everybody who
speaks another language I look at them
as if they have a power I could never
possess and that's when all of my
daughter goes just take a lesson already
yeah I can't hear you talk about this
anymore well ironically a great place to
take lessons is in the actual place
because we're giving away a seven nine
eights day for two adults to a five-star
hotel that Jenny what is the name of the
hotel is Hotel
it's gorgeous there's a I don't mean I
don't even know infinite pools there
every kind of sauna you would ever want
the food is incredible
look how beautiful it is literally one
of Austria's most luxurious Resorts and
Retreats and it's a trip valued at over
twelve thousand dollars
someone in our audience is going to win
this yes get your raffle tickets out
they're on your seat maybe let's send
some good energy that it goes to a fun
person all right are you guys ready help
me do a drum roll
[Applause]
okay great okay the hills are alive with
what number
the winner is number 662.
[Applause]
awesome you said 62 right
62.2 what's your name Olivia hi
congratulations thank you I'm so excited
oh my gosh
[Applause]
you have a friend that you could take on
this trip perhaps I think I'm probably
gonna take my mom
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Jenny Mullen New
York Times best-selling author and
amazing contributor to our magazine next
one and a half million followers on Tick
Tock are obsessed with her advice they
call her the big sister of tick tock
because tinks she's here sharing her
summer favorites we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign